hi all cigarettes - spirit back and
welcome back to someone really know why
we call that it's more like create so
someone that you bros wanted me to Fabul
I see someone that's already been
families a lot Nicolas Cage alright
let's do it
oh god I don't know what's more creepy
honestly yeah I think he looks beautiful
no one can argue that there are of
course some details that are missing
what the [ __ ] am I looking at I'm
getting a little inspired nice nice she
looked like she was born by a dolphin
I'm so sorry - this little girl it's not
my fault maybe that's my fault actually
it's 100% my fault
Oh God why Nicolas why did you do that
[ __ ] you may ask yourself what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me
and the I don't have an answer on any
prisoners out there he deserves to be
beautiful I still feel like it's missing
some oh [ __ ]
I think it looks quite stunning I like
the little peaky nipples who has peaking
nipples that Peaks on you everyone is
like oh no don't pick out my nipples
Nicolas Cage nipples peeks at you much
fab such page was a little inspired by
this one I would say all right let's
move on to the next one Oh Sarah why did
you have to have that face why did you
have to have that face Sarah I went to
meet the fabulous it's not my fault
everyone thinks Sarah looks like either
a foot or a horse oh my god so it's by
it
so what's probably about this picture is
I I want it to be frontal but her face
is a little tilted but that's easily
adjusted through some simple tricks that
you do it does come with a cost I'm
looking like a bit stage but tight you
want a straight face you you got a
sacrifice ever made holy [ __ ] oh yeah
I'm tired I'm sorry oh god Sarah Sarah
don't look at me like that I take it
back Sarah actually now it's better
as long as the eyes are coordinated
properly you see that's let's take a
look at that before before after bad nut
straight face perfect horizontal
remember that next time someone takes a
picture you [ __ ] keep your face
straight where this [ __ ] happens you
actually have a good pair of feet for
you
you see immediately how well they blend
with our face so I understand now where
everyone is coming from this is not just
a coincidence maybe she was a foot Lord
in some ancient Greek mythology or some
[ __ ] like that
I wouldn't be surprised I mean just for
people like different things maybe Sarah
will find someone that like barely any
Photoshop ID all put into this so her
eyes were a little bit bad qualities I'm
taking another pair of eyes just look at
before-and-after before yeah I guess
this just confirms a real review all
right well I guess I can leave the wall
pink for this one as well good old Bob
oh that's cute that's cute you know I
would be even cuter you can barely tell
the difference holy [ __ ]
oh god he's creepy time stop it stop it
Tom oh no this is this is where I go too
far what's what's wrong with me Oh God
you know you know it's gonna become bad
if you bring nip Oh God
okay you know what let's [ __ ] roll
with it I don't see why not imagination
[Music]
imagination alright another one
beautiful is mate let's take a look at
therefore all right so before after even
my final form I'm sorry what nothing
okay suck my nipples no first tweet you
need help
[Laughter]
you ought to see my fix shares all
you're hearing then we have sorry
Jessica Parker hey why I barely footage
up anything on this one I know pretty
handsome food alright I don't know if I
ever did Justin it's pretty hot I mean
he only looks a lot better I never
thought he would look better I'm on I'm
a miracle worker
okay I'm actually pretty surprised how
how good this looks
he's a pretty attractive woman what can
I say I don't know
he got sex yet I know right I mean not
that he was sick you're really enjoying
yourself aren't you yep a bearded lady
[Laughter]
God I gotta try this
Oh God turned out more derpy that I
thought so creepy
kawaii my reaction to everything in life
[Laughter]
stop well I said it was the last one
super Cowie my lady boner is dead what's
that oh I press that's all the time I
had for Fabul izing people today let me
know he wanted me to fabulae snacks it's
really fun for me I love I love just
[ __ ] around with Photoshop is
practically what I do every day with
thumbnails anyway so maybe like I've
been doing watching I really appreciate
it it's this kind of coma birthday I'll
see you breasts in the next one
hey Allison love you
[Music]
[Music]